if you like the wrong tweet you might
get your ass beat case in point what's
being done to Dr Mark Tycho sinski he's
the one there on the left
the president of Thomas Jefferson
University in war-torn Philadelphia a
city known for cheesesteaks and getting
shot while ordering cheese steaks
Oh I thought that we get a better laugh
they just mildly chuckled at the
shooting he was publicly rebuked for
liking tweets critical of coveted
vaccines child sex changes and college
diversity offices and so the Philly
Enquirer became the Inquisition ginning
up the scandal after Anonymous
University employees tattled on the guy
I still remember when people like that
were called snitches and people like cat
gave them stitches
yeah and so the paper really did some
hardcore investigative work it took a
deep dive into all of his past Twitter
likes mind you they're doing this in
Philly a city that recorded two years in
a row with 500 homicides a piece so as
the bodies pile up this is the story
they choose to pursue tweets they must
really be okay with getting murdered
well I mean they support the Phillies
then I don't even know anything about
baseball said one nameless fool some of
the views he endorses calling to
question the University's commitment to
diversity and inclusion and would be
hurtful to trans identifying students oh
man and students of color
translation he doesn't like it when we
don't cut off kids wieners
so it all goes back to wokeness or as
it's more commonly known head up your
ass syndrome now the dude's defending
himself from the mob saying he liked the
tweets to bookmark them for later you
know next thing you know he's going to
tell us he only reads Playboy for the
articles
and it's about time University stop
pretending to care about free speech I
mean imagine if they decided to
investigate my liked tweets what could
they conclude I mean here's one
[Laughter]
another
then there's this one
I mean I guess you could tell I'm really
into fitness
you know Brooke uh hi
these people that are narking are are
work at the University their University
employees
and they they are going after some guy
for for basically liking a tweet yeah
what is going on with this are these is
this a problem with all human beings now
is that they're just a bunch of
and part in my language you know Greg we
have been talking about this me and you
what I love about you so much is that
you are such a champion of free speech
and you know like I do that the only
thing more dangerous than hate speech is
political correctness because political
correctness equals the death of free
speech and I wrote my first book about
this you had me on when I wrote it and
at that time people were coming after me
they were coming after people on Fox
News who were talking about islamist
terrorism theologically motivated
terrorism they were calling us
islamophobic they were trying to shut us
down they were filing lawsuits against
us fast forward we are in the Bizarro
world where you cannot even say a boy is
a boy and a girl is a girl and that is
getting you canceled that is the natural
uh progression of what happens with
political correctness and it is the
greatest danger I want to say one more
thing he was trying to raise awareness
also about the diverse diversity and
Equity inclusion issues happening on
campuses across the United States that
are mostly funded by foreign countries
like Qatar and like Saudi Arabia this is
the greatest national security threat
that is posed to this country right now
put that on a t-shirt
[Laughter]
s
what did you make what did you make of
the the that the the the employees
concerns over his tweets about what
about who he was possibly harming these
are the same people who counseled a
black woman for being on a service
and then this man was liking he he had
liked the tweet that was against kids
getting sex changes and yeah I mean you
know what that kind of triggered me can
I vent a little bit yeah you know
because they were they were mad he liked
the stuff that was against you know
transitioning
when I was growing up
and I didn't have anybody to advocate
for me I always felt like I was a tall
black man trapped in a fun-sized body
always and I wanted to get uh I wanted
to get surgery become taller the doctors
wouldn't even touch my knees
just all I ever wanted to be was taller
because I felt like that inside yes but
I couldn't get a I couldn't get I
couldn't get surgery on my knees but
these kids are but but then I would have
been allowed to get my candy bar cut off
I don't get it it's stupid you know that
um should should he have had to explain
himself that's kind of sad
I think we just have so many
conversations about people like him and
then not enough conversations about who
are the people who are going through
someone else's liked tweets from forever
ago sitting there what is your life like
right and what you're gonna do with your
spare time is go to someone else's
profile click the like area and then
just scroll down and look at all of
these things
um I mean just because you do that you
bring this person down that doesn't
suddenly make you a college President
right it's pathetic I think maybe people
like that haven't reached the level of
success that they've wanted to in lot
their life because there's no reason I
mean I have never in my life gone
through someone's likes except for that
one time when I want to figure out when
my ex started banging that other girl
yes
definitely normal
you're trying to tell your parents what
you do as your job and it's like you
basically are a a all monitor a social
media Hall Monitor this is a purge yes
they're intentionally going after people
at institutions yeah you know in levels
of authority and positions and taking
them down because they're not buying
this woke ideology I mean this gentleman
was a molecular is a molecular
immunologist yeah that sounds quite
intelligent yes and they're trying to
silence him for speaking the truth yes I
was just going to point out this stuff
doesn't happen at the community college
I attended right
the dean's not even on Twitter he's on
MySpace
grinder
right now
what's happening in universities is
they're being plagued by it's like
Conformity cops where they're just
pistol whipping people into complying
with that conformist Progressive mindset
but the difference with Conformity cops
and real cops is the song goes bad thems
bad thems what you're gonna do instead
of Bad Boys you know yeah but here's the
problem
[Applause]
it took a minute though it took a minute
that was a time release joke but here's
the thing what what the problem is what
they're silencing oftentimes is accurate
one of the things he took heat from was
liking tweets that said the vaccine
didn't stop transmission right and the
vaccine didn't stop transmission right
but we spent more energy going after the
guy who called that out than the people
who sold us the vaccine you know what I
mean yeah and think about what they did
they changed the sale it went from you
can't get covered to oh well you'll get
covered but it'll be better do you
remember right of course and everyone
who got coveted was like oh I got covid
but thank God I got the vaccine now I'm
getting a booster yeah which is like me
saying oh my wife's pregnant but thank
God we used a condom you know what I
mean
so so important because there really is
a very easy solution to this it's
everybody who is watching now everybody
in the audience go to his Twitter
retweet it and say I support you you're
speaking the truth do not let him get
canceled use our free speech to support
him aren't you a little Renegade
you've been an activist since you were
born hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else